[Applaudissements]
mon objectif c'est d'être parmi les
meilleurs donc c'est de faire de mon
mieux pour aller le plus vite possible
la Route du Rhum c'est un bateau c'est
une course qui est pas trop faite pour
les bateaux à dérive droite mais bon on
n'est pas à l'abri de bonne condition
climatiques qui nous font aller vite au
début donc moi mon objectif c'est d'être
parmi les meilleurs et donner le maximum
de ce que j'ai ça change jamais donc je
on est trois acteurs il y a l'océan il y
a mon bateau il y a moi et si tous les
trois ben on travaille bien en harmonie
ça devrait bien le faire
le départ est vraiment difficile on peut
y avoir une tempête à passer c'est
souvent c'est le mois de novembre donc
c'est les tempêtes hivernales dans
l'Atlantique donc d'abord il faut passer
cette tempête il faut passer sous le cap
de sous la latitude de Lisbonne et là
après on touche les alizés c'est
beaucoup plus simple même si on est
toujours pas arrivé parce que les alizés
peuvent être compliqués notamment le
matin enlever du soleil là on peut avoir
des grains très très puissants et la
grosse difficulté c'est passé l'hiver
j'ai un bateau mythique c'est Hubert qui
a gagné le Vendée Globe en 2007-2008 il
vient le bateau de Jean Le Cam à qui
j'ai loué le bateau et j'adore mon
bateau en sortant super bien et je pense
que je vais être très triste de le
rendre à Jean Lecam après l'arrivée de
la Route du Rhum
[Applaudissements]